hello and welcome to swipe coming up
start your engines we're trackside this
week with the old electric world of
formula e mad from Kirby's to streaming
sticks the latest on the new tech that
set to hit shelves robot restaurants
move over Gordon Ramsay of r2d2 wants
your job and a blast from the past we're
talking retro games that are still going
strong on this week's games reviews
competition as we all know is great for
putting boundaries of Technology nowhere
is that more prominent than in sport
right now teams around the world led by
celebrities like Leonardo DiCaprio and
Sir Richard Branson gearing up for the
start of formula e the world's first
all-electric Formula One series it's
hoped that the technology developed from
a fierce rivalry on the track will lead
to improvements of electric cars on the
roads to find out more we send Joe tidy
along to the final tests at a circuit in
France
formula e cars quiet out of the paddock
and in like a spaceship on the track for
motorsport fans it's the sound of these
all-electric cars that might take some
getting used to for the drivers and
their teams it's the technology that's a
whole new ballgame just over four months
to go until the start of the
championship and final testing has taken
place here in central France soon all
ten teams will be given their cars but
it doesn't matter if you're Sir Richard
Branson or Leonardo DiCaprio all teams
are being given the same tech organizers
have spent 18 months getting the 150
mile per hour zero emissions cars ready
everything from the engines to the tires
have been tested and chosen for the
teams to make sure everyone starts on a
level playing field in September but
it's no big secret that there are a lot
of unknowns we expect to ever a good
would see a good championship from
September we are although they kill
yourself at the that's going to open
it's a big challenge the ultimate aim of
this eye-catching celebrity backed sport
is to kick-start the electric car
revolution sparking much-needed
innovation
pit lane rivalry in Formula One and
other motorsport is said to have led to
many things we now routinely use on the
road superfast ignition buttons were
originally invented for the track and
now used in many production cars tire
designs evolved from racing innovation
and the disc brakes you probably have on
your wheels come from racing too but
before we can benefit from formula e it
needs to be a success motoring
journalists are cautiously optimistic
I'm really looking forward to year two
of this program because this was just
this is just the first step in stone
single make our single engine single
batteries provider what they're going to
do in the future is open that up to all
sorts of different manufacturers it can
come along with their own technologies
bring in all sorts of things like
hybrids flywheels all sorts of
zero-emission their technology you'll
really like the i think you'll make the
sport fly one of the areas that formula
ii will need to improve on is battery
life at the moment drivers have to
switch cars halfway through the race
before they run out of power organizers
say it's another quirk for this new
sport they're hoping will attract a
younger audience and for millions it
will be hard to miss with race is being
held in ten city centers around the
world including London Joe tidy sky
knees you're watching swype coming up
the robot chefs that are cooking up a
storm but first each week hundreds of
gadgets hit the markets and sorting the
must-haves from the march height can be
tricky one man who's seen it all is
pocket-lint Stewart miles so we asked
him to talk us through what's new from
TV streaming sticks to a device which
can help you create your own Wi-Fi
hotspot on the go so I've been playing
with a new device called the Goodspeed
it's quite boring its box like it
basically is at a mobile mifi that works
in a number of countries to try and save
you cash when you travel normally what
happens when you go to the US for
example is you log on you start paying
data roaming costs and you come home to
a pretty hefty bill the idea with this
is that you pay a rather large two
hundred odd pounds up front but then
every time you go to the states or any
other country that they offer support in
your pay round about five six euros a
day for 500 Meg
now of course there are other ways of
doing this three for example in the UK
offers you a chance to free data roam in
US and if you travel to a specific
country a lot it might be worth checking
out getting a specific sim for that
country and a certain day package and
signing up for a contract the connected
TV streaming box ecosystem is really
heating up at the moment you've got
everybody from Apple to google to Amazon
to Roku playing trying to vie to make
your television incredibly intelligent
the latest is the Roku hdmi streaming
stick which has taken their current
technology in a box about this size and
shrunk it into a little stick that plugs
into your HDMI socket on the back of
your TV once done you then get access to
a load of services like BBC iPlayer
Netflix and now TV Sky News and about
500 other channels most of which are
pretty useless the good thing though
about this is that it's pretty hidden
until you realize that you have to power
it and here's the cable that goes there
so it's not just a case of sticking this
in the back that said once you do to
that you can use the remote to power
everything make your television more
intelligent than it currently is and get
a wealth of services that are available
at around 50 pounds it is more expensive
than some of the offerings from now TV
or Google with their chromecast for
example but it does work and there is
potential for it to grow in the future
so before Christmas one of the big
Christmas toys was the Furby but now
Christmas is over is probably getting a
bit tired and boring and may have been
found that he's been left on a shelf
introducing Furby furbling Hasbro hoping
to change all that I have launched the
fur blings little baby Furbys that well
are as intelligent as the original Furby
boom but do talk and make silly noises
they also connect to the app so you can
have a bit of fun there but if you do
have the original Furby it just so
happens we have one here they can just
try and wake him up they can talk to
each other it had to squeeze this one to
make you make a noise charming and this
hot they're hot respond obviously it's a
bit of a gimmick is a bit of fun but it
should live some more life into the
product at 15 pound
ones and this one's 65 pounds there
about they are fairly expensive although
just has will make you quite giggle
until you get frustrated and throw them
halfway across the room you're watching
swype coming up forever blowing bubbles
the idea for technology that really pops
but first here at swipe when it comes to
food we've been known to get more than
little excited with how tech can
transform what we taste but how about
having a helper in the kitchen that
could take all of the hard work out of
cooking when in China a robot restaurant
has been drawing in the crowds staffed
by robot chefs and robot waiters as Toby
Sadler's been finding out for futuristic
foodies this is the place to be the
mechanical master chefs at this
restaurant in northeast China have been
causing quite a stir taking charge of
the kitchen to grab stir-fries noodles
and dumplings I think this robot can
cook dishes we manually put food
materials into the cabinet and then we
just press one button robot handles it
all certainly the stress levels aren't
quite what you'd find in your typical
professional kitchen and humans aren't
yet surplus to requirement give me an e
on earth a bell here we've lots of
buttons every button represents a table
so we press a button and then the robot
will take the dishes or dumplings to the
table it's certainly proving a hit with
local diners yeah it really is a very
interesting experience either oh hi
Randall the dishes taste just like
they've been made by human chefs if no
one had told me I think we wouldn't have
noticed the difference while it's
unlikely to win a Michelin star anytime
soon these robotic Gordon Ramsay's are
satisfying diners on entertainment value
alone Toby Sadler sky knees you're
watching swype coming up a blast from
the past we're taking a look at some
gaming classics in this week's review
but first here's a roundup of anything
you might have missed over the last few
days Apple has announced plans to pay
large dividends to its shareholders it
follows a healthy set of quarterly
results the company reported profits of
6.1 billion pounds in the three months
tomorrow
the company sold 40 3.7 million iPhones
that's a 17 the percent increase
shareholders will now get six new shares
in exchange for each one they hold
reducing the price from over five
hundred dollars making them more
attractive to smaller investors
meanwhile Facebook has seen profits
triple thanks to a surge in mobile
advertising sales it posted profits of
383 million pounds advertising revenue
was up by eighty-two percent the
majority comes from mobile ads total
daily users were up twenty one percent
from a year ago to 802 million six
hundred nine million were mobile users
when it comes to the broader sector then
actually we can see that there are a
huge number of investors of venture
capitalists that are really looking for
the next big thing and so what some
people are calling a bubble is actually
an awful lot of people taking what are
probably quite conscious Gamble's that
maybe they'll be backing the next
Facebook or the next Apple because
that's where the next set of serious
profits are going to come from the NYPD
has been feeling blue this week after an
attempt to use social media to connect
with the Big Apple backfired
spectacularly it asks New Yorkers to
send pictures of officers being friendly
to hashtag my NYPD but were swamped
instead by somewhat unflattering shots
of cops in action a spokeswoman for the
NYPD has insisted the uncensored and
open dialogue has been good for the city
there was another milestone for social
media this week as the world's biggest
football club sacked its manager on
twitter manchester united announced they
parted company with david moyes in a
short tweet they even helpfully billed
it as breaking news perhaps because the
internet had been swamped by predictions
of his exit for the previous 24 hours a
Kickstarter project to bring a mini
robot printer to market has raised over
a quarter of a million pounds in funding
given how smartphones and tablets have
made it easy for us to work pretty much
anywhere these days the Israeli startup
argues it's time that we had mobile
printers pocket-sized it apparently
prints from your phone on to any size
page
now scientists at Bristol University
have been busy making smart bubbles this
is their Kronos sensory midair display
system which allows bubbles to be filled
with sense or have pictures projected
onto them it's hoped it could be used to
make gaming more interactive or to
provide a sensory way of learning things
it was around this week a quarter of a
century ago a Nintendo Game Boy first
launched the original might look like a
bit of a brick nowadays but the
trailblazing invention helps bring the
concept of pocket gaming to the masses
to celebrate its 25th birthday with a
little help from Ellie Gibson we thought
we'd take a look at a few golden oldie
games which have stood the test of time
well this week marks the 25th
anniversary of the Gameboy which was not
the first handheld console but certainly
the one that really pioneered the sort
of market and really reached the masses
there's an absolute phenomenon globally
and to this day I think it's still very
fondly remembered by gamers all around
the world tetris was designed in 1984 by
the Russian at games designer alexey
pajitnov and it came to the west about
two years later and it was massively
popular part because it was packaged
with the gameboy when that launched in
1989 alexey pajitnov didn't actually see
any royalties from tetris until nineteen
ninety six because until then he worked
for the Soviet government so they made
quite a lot of money off it but then
when he set up his own company he
started breaking so of course there have
been lots of iterations of Tetris since
the original at most recently there's
been tetris battle which is one the most
popular games on facebook with more than
seven and a half million likes at the
top of the leaderboard there's a guy
who's I think he's played 15 thousand
rounds of the game and he's won fourteen
thousand so yeah I'm not actually at the
top of the leaderboard myself I'm not
actually on it so there you go space
invaders first hit the arcades back in
1978 and went on to sell 360,000 machine
so it really was one of the most popular
arcade games of all time so they've been
tons of space invaders games released
over the years when the more recent ones
with space invaders infinity now this
much a radical departure for the space
invaders series because not only could
your spaceship go left and right but for
the first time it could also go up and
down that was followed in 2010 by space
invaders infinity gene which was
inspired by Darwin's theory of evolution
since the paint as you play the game the
better you get at it the petiole
spaceship gets now the mobile version of
this game actually has a music mode and
this is this pretty revolutionary and
that you can pick a song stored on your
phone and the game will generate a level
that matches the music so yeah I
recommend the Benny Hill theme and first
arrived in the arcades in 1980 it was
originally called pac-man but when it
came to the west the games company
decided to change the name because they
were a bit worried about people
analyzing the first letter on the arcade
cabinets the back then the gameplay was
pretty simple and it's pretty familiar
to a lot of people you're a little
yellow blob chasing around a maze eating
lots of other yellow blobs while being
chased by ghosts but recently the it's
got a bit more complicated than that so
there's been pac-man and the ghostly
adventures released last year which is
actually a 3d platforming game that's
not very good I think they've lost
something of the spirit of the original
really so if you fancy a bit of pac-man
fun you're better off with world's
biggest pac-man which is an online game
and you can create your own mazes that
we can play ones that other people have
designed and it's been hugely popular
around the world with more than two
billion pills pot to date so if you want
to give that one a go it's free to play
and it's world's biggest pac-man calm
that's it for this week remember you can
catch up with all the breaking tech
stories all week on Sky News for iPad or
smartphone apps and sky news com I'll
see you next time